quite a milestone because of course we
started off thinking um that romaine had
won and at half past two quarter three
after nigel farage had already said he
lost it turned out he hadn't lost and it
turned out we were leaving the european
union so that was quite shocking
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle now you've just heard
rebecca vardy's side now hear from
colleen's best friend danielle lloyd
years after the horrific death of baby p
have the right lessons truly been learnt
liz trust superfan jacob rees-mogg will
tell us which government department
should get ready to come into the office
once he becomes their new
minister yummy yum yum yum yum yum yum
which one's going in the oven first
you
and you can't send anything to a lamb
these days gordon ramsay's gob gets him
in trouble again
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening my friends so let's start
with the story that everyone is talking
about the sun and talk tv's exclusive
interview with rebecca vardy on the
wagotha christie saga but my question is
how on earth can anyone keep up with the
twists and the turns so this old man
will try and put it straight in your
head so it all started with this woman
this is colleen rooney and her private
instagram now if you're not sure you
don't know
colleen is married to england's record
goal scorer wayne rooney now while she
didn't mind the likes of you and me
seeing her post there were things she
wanted to keep between her nearest and
her dearest but
these stories will mysteriously leak to
the newspaper so to nail her suspect
colleen rooney made her instagram
stories only visible to one person it
was this woman rebecca vardy fellow wag
and wife of another england striker
jamie now colleen come back here she
then fabricated events happening in her
life post them on her account and waited
to see if they would hit the tabloids
and lo and behold the invented tales
were published she then sent out that
tweet it's rebecca vardy's account
[Music]
vardy responded poetically with the
following i'm not being funny love but i
don't need the money so the argument
continued in court there was a right
libel trial bought by her sorry rebecca
vardy colleen this is her came at thank
you came out on top leaving her rebecca
devastated
and three million quid poorer
i didn't do anything wrong i didn't do
it you know there's
lots of people that probably have given
stories i was
enemy number one and target number one
her team say that they did give you
opportunities to withdraw essentially to
stop this from going as far as it did
you can't
enter into settlement negotiations with
people that are being aggressive
so joining me now is model and colleen
rooney's best mate danielle lloyd how
are you i'm good what a day what a day
what a week i know
i i wanted to ask you actually to start
what i said to somebody earlier why do
you think this story that started on
instagram between
two wags with everything that's going on
in the world the the people who are
suffering all this money all this hassle
why has it captured the imagination of
the public people just love drama
they just love it and
really it could have all been avoided
and it could have just been we wouldn't
be talking about it now the whole court
case didn't happen so when you when you
look at it right and we've heard
rebecca's side today read it in the sun
seen it on talk tv um you know you are a
friend of color you found yourself in
the middle of the saga uh there were
messages look at her face what's that
message is from rebecca and former agent
caroline watts this is the woman who
lost her phone in the sea uh describing
you as a nasty [ __ ]
i know
that's completely wrong isn't it you're
lovely we've met before um apparently
the court was also told that rebecca
threatened to leak stories about you
after the horrible miscarriages yeah
that's true and that was obviously
something like really traumatic that i
obviously didn't want to think about
again and i think it's really horrible
for someone to obviously be trying to
leak stories about something so vile
when you see rebecca vardy on that
interview emotional
saying i will never give up protesting
my innocence until i'm blue in the face
i'm innocent i'm this and i'm that
and she was going to leak a story about
you you say
at such a traumatic time
what do you make of that tonight
i think the lines are very blurred i
think you know she's obviously sitting
there protesting her innocence but these
stories came from her account and
you know there was
whatsapp messages saying that she would
be prepared to leak stories on other
people so why would she not leak them on
colleen you said and talk to you earlier
in the week daniel you said that you
felt like justice has been done yeah how
would you describe rebecca vardy
oh gosh
can i say um
i think
i don't think she's telling the truth
i think you know she's trying to save
face and
and she could have prevented all this
you know i think obviously
it's not nice to be
um targeted by trolls i think that's
horrible and it shouldn't be happening
but um you know there's things the
messages you can't get away from
this this is the point and we'll talk
about um colleen in a moment and and the
toll that all of this is taken but i
never understood
everybody has an opinion right yeah
for me it was just looking in the eyes
and i could see it straight away but
what i don't understand is why she
continued and still continues i mean the
judge said
that vardy clearly knew of condoned or
actively encouraged the leaking of
personal information and that that
basically her her testimony was was not
believable that is damning yeah exactly
but apparently the judge was wrong and
she didn't have a clue let's talk about
colleen your mate um and i've met
colleen and roone and wayne several
times and i like them both and and i'm
just being straight about that um
what's the toll been on colleen
i think it's been really stressful and i
think that's why this whole
why she put that text out because
she'd been through hell for two years
not knowing who's to trust and i think
like going through something like that
must be traumatic you know not knowing
what friends to trust whether it was
family
it's been really hard so i'm glad that
she's found out cleverly who where i
came from colleen has also said that she
would have she would have finished this
she doesn't she didn't want the
spectacle that it became and and
and there is only one person that pushed
for that because rebecca brought the
libel case yeah she did and you know
what
there's one thing that i know about
colleen she doesn't like the limelight
she doesn't want to be
a big celebrity she wants to just be a
mom and you know i'm going to say this
because i've met her a couple of times
and the last time was in an airport and
you know you hear about all these wags
and all the money and all the stuff you
know she's got
there's four kids running around all
over the place she's doing all the stuff
her mum and dad are there wayne's on the
phone obviously in the corner and and
she's a normal girl and you know a lot
of people will criticize colleen rooney
and say oh you've stayed with him
despite all the the things that have
happened she loves that man she loves
her her family is the most important
thing to her exactly and you think about
what this did to the kids as well right
yeah like obviously on both sides like
rebecca's and colleen's kids like it's
just not been nice for any of them i'm
sure they've been getting bullied in
school and stuff like that like because
kids can be cruel um
and social media abuse to them both to
the kids that just on goes as well right
exactly like the court case never had to
happen
no
this interview that rebecca did tonight
didn't have to happen
it could have all been prevented what
would you say to rebecca vardy after
that tonight and after the last and and
after everything what would you say to
her
honestly like
there was part of that interview that i
just sat there and laughed like it was
it was hard to watch it was actually
quite
a cringe if you were her would you now
give up the ghost and go away and and
try and get on with your life quietly or
like colleen's done you know she hasn't
done an interview or she's just said
like let's get on with our lives it's
over it's done and just move on and
be happy
or try well she hasn't because she's
allegedly i should say allegedly
otherwise i get into trouble signed up
for a documentary and i wonder in all of
this what jamie makes at this apart from
the bill three million quid apparently
the portuguese villa might need to go
there'll be people who can't afford to
pay their you know their electricity
bills going oh bless they've got to get
rid of the villa but it just didn't seem
to make sense did it no there was a lot
of things in there you know that she
said like oh i would never leak a story
on someone but in text messages you've
said that you would be prepared to she
said she didn't need the money and but
then there was a a text in there that
said i won't pay him for this one now
there's a lot of blade lines so blurred
line with the agent as well i know she's
had mental health issues so we can't get
into too much detail but that phone in
the sea i mean honestly that was like
that
you'd love to get that phone wouldn't
you um just to finish you are a good
friend of colleen um how is she doing
no i haven't actually spoken to her and
even if i did i don't think i would say
because i think this whole thing is
about privacy and i think obviously i
respect colleen's privacy and
silence is golden though isn't it keep
your powder dry daniel lloyd always a
pleasure great mum great to have you on
thank you next on uncensored rishi sunak
and liz trust have been fielding
questions from the party faithful in
tonight's latest hustings in cardiff but
what does cabinet minister jacob
rees-mogg made a make of it all i'll be
speaking to him after this break
exclusively stay with us i'm coming back
in three
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
jeremy khan and with the latest hugo of
times poll showing liz trust might as
well start inputting the queen's mobile
into a phone tory heavyweights are now
falling over themselves to belatedly
endorser this week saw former rivals tom
tugan hat and penny morton both declared
that they always knew trust would make a
great prime minister and even in the
last hour breaking news sajid javid
rishi's partner in boris backscap
stabbing crime has endorsed the foreign
secretary one man however who has been
riding the right horse since day one
good friend of mine uh jacob reese
morgan the number one fan of the number
one candidate joins me now live jacob
good evening thank you for making it
talk tv how are you
oh good evening i'm very well and thank
you for inviting me on i feel a bit
guilty because piers invited me on and i
haven't yet managed to come on with him
so i'm sort of sneaking in while she's
on holiday who
mr morgan that's showbiz look what
happened to bojo it happens jacob um i
want to start because one of the things
and we'll talk about the tory leadership
in a bit but one of the things that has
happened whilst liz trust and rishi
sunak do do do what they're doing across
the country is that many people have
said that the government is paralyzed
you though sir have been getting on with
your job and today uh you made a new
announcement about tackling fraud
benefit tell us more
yes it's very important that the
government carries on even whilst we're
in the process of getting a new leader
and tackling fraud against the
government is really important so the
public sector fraud authority which was
launched today will have the powers to
bring together all the data across
government to set targets for individual
departments and on a budget over three
years of 25 million pounds should save a
minimum of 180 million pounds in fraud
which makes great fiscal sense it leads
me to ask only one question why now
jacob why not before
oh well we've been working on this since
i've been the um minister for government
efficiency uh taking on the work that
lord agnew was doing and lord agnew
resigned as you may remember because he
was finding that government simply
wasn't getting on with this properly and
his resignation acted as a real catalyst
to force departments to take this more
seriously so i'm very grateful to the
work that lord agnew did which i've been
carrying on and we were going to launch
two or three weeks ago
but there was a sudden change in the
mandate produced by the treasury which
we had to get corrected before we could
launch it properly today because we
wanted to do it in a way that would be
effective what you're saying without
being disrespectful is that the change
of leadership in the treasury has made
it easier for you to bring it in what
would you say to people who would say
25 million for 180 million makes great
fiscal cents what about the 15 billion
that was fraudulently used up sadly
during the pandemic what would you say
about that jacob
that's absolutely right and one of the
reasons for the public sector fraud
authority is to ensure that when the
government is handing out money in
future it builds in processes that will
make fraud more difficult in a way like
the banknote issuance that you know
banknotes every
um year or so improve the quality of the
printing to make it harder for
fraudsters we have to do the same with
government schemes to make it constantly
harder for fraudsters to get through
and that is what the public sector
authority will do
and two years ago in defense of what was
done the urgency was simply to get money
out to make sure that businesses had the
funds that they required
and it's only with hindsight that we've
seen how much fraud there has been um
jacob last night we had a colonel bob
stewart on the show we were talking
about the thing that i know
is absolutely central to so many
people's lives the length and breadth of
this country which is the cost of living
crisis and just want to play you a clip
because i said to him when you wake up
wherever you are in the uk and you read
that a company like bp has made 6.9
billion pounds profit in three months
and people are literally struggling to
make ends meet something has to be done
watch this from colonel bob if you'd be
so kind
i say we've got to actually look at
these profits because they're immoral
actually their their money taken out of
all of us we've actually got to see how
we can actually reduce them and actually
give that back to the people that
actually make them make the companies
have the profits i.e the people that
sounds very socialist but i'm afraid i'm
i'm feeling that way myself how do you
respond to that jacob
well i'm i have the greatest admiration
for um bob he is a first-class member of
parliament um but on this i don't agree
with him
that
two years ago the height of the pandemic
the oil price was below zero and oil
companies had to pay for their oil to be
taken away it didn't last very long but
oil prices don't go one way they fall as
well as rise and we need strong oil
companies that can provide us with the
energy that we need one of the reasons
for the high price of energy is that we
haven't maximized investment in our own
resources we haven't maximized the
extraction from the north sea and we
haven't done shale gas in the way that
we ought to have done if we're to put
that right we need oil companies that
can invest and we need a stable
investment environment and the profits
that a company like bp makes
don't exist in isolation that they get
paid out to pension funds which then
ensure pensioners have a reasonable
standard of living so they are part of
the whole economic system do you as a a
traditional tory briefly what do you
think this government should could or is
going to do about this cost of living
crisis that really is
biting deep now as we approach winter
yes well the government has already
announced 37 billion pounds of support
for people and people will already have
got 326 pounds i think has gone to the 8
million least well off in this country
to help them and there is more money
going out during the course of the year
and liz trust has proposed getting rid
of the green levy which seems to me to
be a penal
tax on people under current
circumstances but we've got to tackle
the underlying causes so we need to get
our own sources of gas out particularly
and that means shale gas because we want
to get back to situation where we're not
dependent on fluctuations in the
international price for gas so that's i
get that very important i get that and
you and i have spoken many times before
and i want to move on but i will say
this so just i worry that in 2022 the
fifth richest nation in the world we've
got mayors of cities talking about warm
banks because people cannot keep warm in
the winter that does not reflect on us
as a society as a country as a
government that doesn't that doesn't
reflect good on anybody does it jacob it
doesn't that's that's absolutely right
and that's why boris johnson leading the
government that he has been leading and
will continue to lead until early
september took such major steps to put
money in people's pockets are you saying
to me will more need to be done well i'm
almost certain that it will we need to
see what the price cap ends up being but
all the um prognostications all the
forecasts are deeply concerning about
the price of energy but we mustn't
whilst dealing with the short-term
issues forget the longer term problem
which is that we need to be extracting
more energy from our own resources so
that we never become dependent on russia
in this way again okay let's talk about
the leadership rishi and liz tonight
facing questions from welsh conservative
party members the latest hustings in
cardiff you've been
very vocal about liz trust from day one
it seems that the the domino effect is
happening you back the right horse
they're all coming out tonight sajid
javid and the latest opinion poll
showing that over 60 percent want liz
trust and
fishy rishi as i call him is way back on
26
it seems jacob that nothing can stop her
when she wins which i'm fully expecting
her to and i'm sure you are
you said something in january 2020
about a new prime minister if i just
play this clip because it's actually
relevant to tonight's conversation
so if we are looking at how the
constitution has evolved it is clear
that a prime minister has a personal
mandate much more than a party mandate
that that mandate is one that comes from
voters who would expect to renew it in
the event of a change of prime minister
and that is why i think we have evolved
to the situation where a new prime
minister would want a new election
do you still stand by that jay always
dropped his phone brilliant i love it i
have yeah
don't worry clearly
there we go the telephone is now i think
back in place um
what what i was saying then was about
the evolution of the constitution
and i was actually saying the same thing
in 2011 before the fixed time parliament
act it's why i opposed the fixed term
parliament act
because i thought it went against the
grain of our constitutional evolution i
think the mandate has become
increasingly personal and we will see
time will tell
whether the evolution has completed or
not all right
fast questions to finish because i don't
want your phone to fall off and you've
always been amazing to come on with us
uh does liz trust win
well i think it's very unwise to make
predictions whilst debate is taking
place i'm fully supporting her i would
encourage all your viewers to vote for
her if they're members of the
conservative party i think she'll be an
excellent prime minister but i'm not
going to tempt fate has she offered you
a job
no of course not she'd be quite wrong to
be making promises to people i'm
supporting her because i think she will
be the best candidate to lead the
country in the conservative party
there's been reports that that that you
and the dean doris two of boris's most
you know fervent supporters for good
reason nadine's been quite you know
vocal there have been criticisms about
tweets where do you stand on that jacob
oh
look i'm i'm not the most obsessive
tweeter
and i'm not going to make further
attacks on rishi sunak i think his
policies speak for themselves and his
economic policy has approached the
treasury of following treasury orthodoxy
has not had the most beneficial outcome
for the british economy and therefore
i'm not supporting him on policy grounds
i i'm sure he is
a very decent individual and he's
certainly a very clever individual
um you admitted you got your comment on
dover wrong this week i have to say it
made me grin a little bit but i'll
probably get into trouble
when you look back over the last three
years under boris johnson what else has
this government got wrong brexit what
what what do you see as problems that
could have been done differently
no but as i explained in my comment the
reason for the cues is the french not
the british and that's what i was saying
at the time um the cues are created
because the french haven't sent enough
people to deal with them they have
manned the booths that have been made
available now if the french don't want
people to go to france then the british
people can go to other countries seems
to be perfectly sensible rational thing
to do
um so actually i think boris johnson has
got all the big issues right he got
brexit right he delivered it he got us
through the pandemic he dealt with the
vaccine rollout and in international
affairs he has ensured the most
exceptional uk leadership in dealing
with russian aggression in ukraine so i
think the overall scorecard for boris
johnson is that we have had an
absolutely fine prime minister and it is
very sad that he has been forced out
how's he doing he described it the way
at the the wedding party at the weekend
were you there he he said that it was a
bigger stitch up than the buyer
tapestries one of the greatest lines
ever is that what he said
i'm not going to say what was said at
the private event i'm it's not not you
know you know i'm not going to do that
but the pm remains in very chirpy form
he he's not a doomster and a gloomster
he's a booster
and he puts into practice um what he
preaches he's always a very positive
individual and believes in that proper
british virtue of the stiff upper lip
when things don't go entirely to plan
jacob um it's always a pleasure you're
always straight and honest i've no doubt
you'll be liz trust his cabinet i'll be
back on to your people to get you back
on but thank you so much for joining us
tonight thank you jacob
thank you goodbye bless you jacob reese
mark gets a little story now actually i
i rang to speak jacob's removing his
phone there i rang to speak to jacob on
monday and and this is genuinely what
happened he went uh prime minister and i
went no it's jesus and he went you're
the only two people i know with a
withheld number so there you go it
happens next and uncensored as the war
in ukraine rumbles on tensions between
china and taiwan are intensifying the
big question has the ukraine war set the
stage for more conflict in our world
we'll discuss that next after this break
we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
this is talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
jeremy khanna as the brutal and tragic
war in ukraine continues the fragile
balance of harmony between the global
powers seems more precarious than ever
tension between china and the u.s
yesterday reached new heights after
house speaker nancy pelosi visited
taiwan in response china today undertook
live fire combat training in the tuan
strait and that good old north korea's
weighed in warning the states to stay
out of their politics i guess the
question is has the war in ukraine paved
the way for more conflict around the
world delighted to be joined now by
colonel jake a former commander of
british forces in afghanistan also major
john spencer who is chair of the urban
warfare studies at the madison policy
forum excuse me but first cormac smith
good friend of mine and former advisor
to the ukrainian foreign minister lovely
to see you cormac um
pelosi yesterday
the al-qaeda man taken out over the
weekend this vacuum in afghanistan and
the talk of this access you know this
this axis of russia and china and iran
when you look at ukraine
is this war
is what russia is doing is a precursor
for worse things in your opinion
good evening it's lovely to see you
again look um
i think we're at 12 minutes to midnight
and i go back to a speech that sergey
lavrov made at the munich security
conference in february in 2017
when he almost rejoiced in the breakup
of the post war
um order that had given us the rules
based order that had given us the you
know the greatest period of prosperity
and and and security that the world has
ever known and he talked about the
emergence of the post-west era
and he talked about how nato was a cold
war relic quite honestly
quite honestly i think that you know we
were not listening at the time or paying
or paying attention and the issues that
we have now with nancy pelosi and and
china and taiwan
is very very worrying the chinese will
sit back i think and they will play a
long game i agree with you let's bring
in major john spencer military scholar
and combat veteran um major spencer
thank you for joining us tonight nancy
pelosi's visit to tehwan was was met
with sort of incredulous disbelief by
many people over this side of the pond
you know she arrived in taiwan in this
sort of air force jet we heard nothing
from biden and i think many people over
here are thinking
was he privately supporting it why was
nothing publicly said because on the
surface and you might tell me
differently hasn't that stoked the fire
between the us and china
i mean you can't argue that it didn't i
mean i think president biden's comments
that were bold and said we will defend
taiwan was enough
of strategic aim to giddy so basically
her visit is another sign saying we will
defend democracy around the world this
isn't i agree with um this is the
greatest test to the rule-based order
since world war ii and if you just fall
asleep at the will it will end up in
major war
i i'd like to bring him as well if if i
can um
and delighted to have him on the show
colonel richard kemp former commander of
british uh forces in afghanistan uh keno
richard many people talking about that
vacuum left after the us removed
themselves from afghanistan but over the
weekend the al-qaeda man taken out by
the americans the question for everybody
is who's next when where where is this
all in for people watching this tonight
what should we be thinking what should
we be fearing if you like
well i think one of the shocking things
was that um
bin laden's successor was living a life
of comfort in the center of kabul two
decades after the u.s went in with its
allies including the uk
to get rid of al qaeda to get rid of the
taliban and now we've got the taliban
ruling again
as a result of
president biden's
horrendous foreign policy to withdraw
unconditionally
in such really dire circumstances that
showed the world
how very weak the united states is and
nato as well because of course nato went
rushing out with the americans and
there's no doubt in my view that that's
was monitored and looked at carefully by
putin and that was a factor i think
america and nato's weakness was a factor
not necessarily the deciding factor but
a significant factor in his decision to
go back in again to ukraine and i think
of course president xi is watching
um the the weakness of from afghanistan
and also what i consider and many other
people would disagree the weakness that
uh nato and the west have shown over
ukraine yeah we've we've provided a
certain amount of military support we
have imposed significant sanctions but
it hasn't been enough because russia is
achieving too much success in ukraine if
i and and and the west has been impotent
naturally
so i think it's provocative i i have to
say i agree with you comic we've spoken
about this many many times before you've
always said to me the west should do
more for ukraine we've talked about you
know the the logistical help we can't
put troops on the ground but is this
sending a message to china that putin
has gone into ukraine and yes there are
sanctions and yes there's international
outrage but he's still there and maybe
china's looking at taiwan and going well
actually we could do the same that's
what we're talking about right i think
it's too early to draw a conclusion yet
there are green shoots of recovery
coming out of ukraine certainly and
these new weapons which the other two
gentlemen on the panel will
be far better qualified to talk about
than myself but the highmars are making
the ukrainians are making very smart use
of them and they are making a big big
difference there's also evidence that um
as general lord danette said recently
that russia has shot its bolt to quote
him directly there is evidence that
their advance is slowing down
significantly so i think china is still
watching my point what i've made to you
is we simply cannot allow ukraine to
lose a very good ukrainian friend of
mine senior diplomat said recently
if ukraine
if ukraine wins
there is no war
if ukraine loses there is no ukraine
well this is really interesting i bring
major spencer back in from the states um
john the interesting thing is um the
americans are undoubtedly looking at
what's happened in ukraine as i guess
china is do you think america
could have been stronger yes we know
about the al-qaeda thing but it i i i
just wonder whether china is sitting
there waiting and and you know a cynic
said to me today did pelosi go to taiwan
with biden's you know with his with his
blessing privately because of the
midterms one doesn't really know i have
to say from a personal point of view
what the american administration truly
thinks right now
yeah absolutely i think that america did
not
they're failing ukraine today in my
opinion and we failed ukraine in the
beginning
and china is not russia if we wait six
months to help to go full in we should
still have it in ukraine just an aid to
taiwan taiwan won't survive a month
um russia is a test of the world order
and he he's achieving what he wanted and
if we don't stop him
in ukraine then this does lead to
a complete unraveling of the global
order that we've all enjoyed since post
war ii i think we all agree and i'd love
to have more time gentlemen i i haven't
i think we all agree that that world
order uh is in danger is threatened and
what will happen over the next few weeks
and months we must watch very closely
major john spencer thank you very much
indeed uh also cormac smith thank you
and also richard kemp i appreciate all
of you being involved tonight thank you
so much indeed
right next on uncensored
i know this is a subject that is
difficult for many people but i wanted
to do it for a reason 15 years on since
the tragic death of baby p the
heartbreaking brutality of the abuse
still suffering appalled britain's the
thing i'm worried about is have lessons
really been learned are we anywhere
better off than we were 15 years ago
we'll discuss that next after this break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
jeremy carr now it's been 15 years since
17 month old baby peter died following
months of abuse at the hands of his mum
tracy connolly step dad stephen barker
and barker's brother jason owen baby p's
death shocked the nation and at the time
it seemed that society came together to
say quite clearly never ever again but
after numerous inquiries reviews and
reforms over the years the list of
children whose lives have been cruelly
taken continues to grow i'm delighted to
be joined firstly by marin hawes founder
of freedom from abuse a charity that
safeguards children we
were talking during the break are things
any better 15 years no no it's worse the
system is broken and that's the reality
from top to bottom and breadth it's
broken 28 years ago we were talking
about the victoria columbia
passing death you remember that lord
lambing at the time issued a brilliant
report of which 70 percent is still
waiting to be adopted
the
the lives of children in this country
are cheap if anybody that's you know you
look at rishi sunak and and also liz
trusts do you hear their mention in the
leadership debate anything about the
brutality of children in this country it
is an embarrassment you know we need
mandatory reporting we need people to be
brought to brooke to not be able to
cover it up in the schools and all the
rest of it where do you stand on and
tracy connolly i don't even want to
spend any time on it because the man is
sick to the stomach but the woman is out
right i know dominick rotten she was
actually released on the 7th of july
dominic robb the justice minister this
is the justice minister okay could not
change the law this woman is is under a
new identity roaming the streets of this
country paid for by the british taxpayer
how does that work i know well it
shouldn't work should it the the law is
an ass quite frankly it's so wrong i
know you've got peter garcia coming on a
minute which is a friend of mine but it
you know we have to have the mandatory
reporting we have to look top to bottom
social social workers are leaving in
their droves and i don't blame them but
even that is wrong
the police look at that absolute dog's
dinner what's going on there
it seems to me i've had a terrible
domestic abuse case i've been dealing
with today and that the police don't
respond it took me
it took me all day yesterday to try and
get a response from the police so i've
actually put in a a a report and i put
in a complaint because there's young
children involved how many children have
been killed recently
oh lessons must be learned if you have
to learn the lessons you shouldn't be in
that position in the first place oh i
feel passionately about this because
every child has the right to be saved
from harm and prevented from harm and
right across it doesn't matter it's the
churches the schools whatever it is
people are still closing their eyes and
ears to it and they don't want to handle
it and a child's life is at risk marilyn
i would i would and i could and i should
talk to you for longer you know and
understand i know i know but i
absolutely go with everything you say
thank you to you next time
appreciate it next time i'm joined by
peter gaston the president of the
association of child abuse lawyers and
paula hudgell who's the mother of uh
six-year-old tony and i have to read
this
this boy was abused so badly by his
birth parents he had to have both of his
legs amputated i
struggle with stories like this um let's
start with you paula if i can thank you
for joining me i want to say something
to start with people like you who adopt
children like that are angels and
heroines i know that you're going
through your own medical issues but if
you could
just explain for people watching what
your son went through at the hands of
abusive parents
hi jeremy um yes so tony um was born a
healthy little boy back in um october
2014
by the time he was 41 days old he was
taken to hospital unresponsive
with multiple fractures
multi-organ failure sepsis toxic shock
he'd been left up to 10 days with
multiple fractures they never ever
expected him to survive
thankfully to our nhs who are absolutely
incredible
they worked tirelessly on him for three
months
at the evelina children's hospital in
london
i met him as i was a foster carer at the
time when he was ready to leave hospital
and brought him home to our family
and we fell in love with him i mean he
was a tiny broken
his legs were still in plaster his arms
had just come out of plaster the day
before he'd had 23 operations eight
blood
transfusions
um and they they just never expected to
survive um
and we went on to adopt him the
following year um we just couldn't part
with him but this was all at the hands
of his biological birth parents um i
said it at the beginning paula people
like you are angels what do you make uh
before i cross to uh peter gaston what
do you make of people like tracy
connolly who are free to roam the
streets of this country now released
despite the justice minister wanting to
change the law what is wrong with our
society that that can happen why is it
happening
oh absolutely i mean i've been in close
contact with dominic rabb over the last
year since we passed tony's law um so
that wouldn't happen now if somebody now
is found um guilty of that offence of a
child dying under causing or allowing
serious harm they will they could be
sentenced to life imprisonment now at
the time for tracy connolly she could
only be
a maximum sentence was 14 years
um and that they they get automatic
parole after half
that's all changed so we are moving
forward with that um and i'm working
close with dominic rob still to push for
a child cruelty register because
actually these once they're out on the
streets you know they could be your
neighbors they could be looking after
your children and you wouldn't know so
we i want to bring in peter garzan if i
can president of the association of
child abuse lawyers peter thank you for
joining us very quickly my friend how in
the name of the lord can this still be
allowed to happen in 2022 how can this
woman roam the streets what is wrong
with our society that we cannot change
laws and get this sorted
well
sadly the process of
reforming legislation is a long and
torturous one
whilst
mps often want to change the law there
isn't sufficient parliamentary time
and then
even when you do change the law you have
to deal with the discretion of a judge
who listens to
mitigation from defense counsel and
imposes uh sometimes uh an unacceptably
lenient sentence but at least now it
didn't actually happen at one time that
sentence can be appealed to the court of
appeal uh and indeed uh that has
happened recently and and censuses have
been increased
people are watching this all over the
types of
people all over the country peter will
be saying one thing they don't know how
this can happen uh the system is is
utterly broken it must be the most
frustrating thing in the world for you
to do that and of course the other thing
that they'll say is that you know covid
and the pandemic will have increased
spiked child abuse in homes all across
this country and i don't have i'd like
to have i could speak about this all
night everybody agrees you know that
this is completely and utterly
unacceptable just very briefly can you
see this situation changing peter in the
not too distant future
i wish i could be optimistic about it
but unfortunately
drugs and
alcohol and poverty and and degradation
and
the the the poverty is getting worse
that can be an accelerating factor covid
was an accelerating factor because a lot
of children stayed with abusive parents
and abusive adults much longer than they
would have done had every not been
locked down and were only now seeing the
effect of the abuse in families that was
made a lot worse by the covert effect
during the two-year lockdown thank you
so much peter final word from you paula
um
you took on this boy you've given him a
life 30 seconds what would you say to
the powers that be about how the world
should change well this country should
change its laws
we need to protect the most vulnerable
in society and and that's what children
are we need to now speak up open up and
if something's not right it needs to be
sorted and the multi-agencies all need
to work together not against each other
together to actually make this work
thank you so so much uh all of you for
taking part in this debate i really
really appreciate it thank you
right i'm joined now by political
commentator marina perkis or pukis i
don't know and leader of the reform uk
party the thais man is back how are you
lovely to meet you we can't stretch that
far i'm you're loving your big new
studio aren't you i have this great
desire to run around i know but i have
to sit here i might run around it anyway
we haven't got all the time in the world
but i'd love it very briefly 30 seconds
each what did you marina make of that i
mean that's appalling i can't believe so
to be honest it's
there should be more money
thrown at this but sadly we've had 12
years of touring austerity and this hits
local authority funding and it is
precisely why there isn't money to
investigate and stop these sorts of
things happening i've been talking about
i would agree but you know this is it's
all the time we have these reports these
reviews and they say we've learned the
lessons they haven't it's still ongoing
and it's absolutely awful and too often
the agencies don't talk to each other
enough and people have got to have the
courage to speak out completely agree uh
jacob reese morgan um you love him don't
you um
let's talk about the tory leadership uh
hustings tonight in cardiff uh the
reform party do you care who you're glad
boris has gone liz or rishi's got to be
list trust all the way isn't it yeah i
mean frankly they should uh they should
bring the end date of this form you know
it's done and dusted yeah the only
question is the extent of sunax
humiliation
and uh liz trust will be the next prime
minister they're all falling into line
they're all falling into line even mps
on sunax team are now quietly sidling up
to the trust team saying
yeah i'm really surprised penny morton
slagged her off something chronic and
now she delivered an oscar speech the
other day when
um
it paralyzes government though this this
this campaign whether they're paralyzed
or not they are completely incompetent
and jacob rees-mogg's interview just now
was
he is a man who has been in
educated beyond his intelligence and
he's a prime example of someone an
evolutionary constitutional evolution he
gave us the reason he flip-flopped
between saying you should have a general
election you shouldn't the man is a
laughingstock he's incompetent he is and
he is a a liar so you're not somebody
who believes the conspiracy theory that
boris will lay low for two years and
come back when liz trust loses the next
thing i think there's every chance i
think
we're talking about parachuting him into
a safe seat oh god
also i think he'll be made the ukraine
envoy and stay in the public eye by liz
trust it will then be a hung parliament
you'll ride back and look at the fear on
titan so far at all i mean it's
inevitable you know he is boris is going
to do what boris does he will earn a
pile of money over the next couple of
years to repay some bills and then watch
out he will be back guys do you feel
responsible because you still have to be
responsible i'm delighted that you stood
down yeah to get brexit done and i'm
thrilled we got brexit down that was the
right to be such a boy it is a fantastic
opportunity is it done it's work in
progress it's a platform of opportunity
himself said that we won't see benefits
for about 40 years
as soon as you've got a government that
believes in it and goes for it and
starts to cut taxes
and go
i've got i've got a couple of minutes
let's talk about the premier league
footballers not all of them taking the
knee next season what do you make of
this marina i think it's fair enough
that it's being reduced but we've got to
look at why they're doing it in the
first place they were trying to get
equality for all and to address the
whole you know systemic racism that
exists in football and beyond did they
achieve it i think they did as much as
they could but essentially the power
falls down to the people that walk up
and down the corridors of the governing
bodies i think i think it raised
awareness david it works for me said
something earlier which i think is great
he would prefer now the clubs okay to
use some money and use the players to go
into the community and re-educate the
people because if you're taking the knee
and imagine the people that clapping
they're not the ones whose minds you
need to change right absolutely and what
needs to happen is a bit of evidence
about actually you know has it helped
what is changing on the terraces of
certain football grounds because it is
in certain grounds and it is still going
on but i think it's improving we all
want it to get down to zero but it's
still there and we've still got to
battle you know on everybody's hands we
can never be complacent and
unfortunately in in men's football
you know this is this is still there and
we learned to didn't we actually about
women's football you know the the
quality of that game on on sunday uh the
atmosphere of the crowd i actually think
men maybe got quite a lot to learn there
was no there was no fighting no fighting
they get fouled and get up we've only
got half a minute very quickly uh
gordon ramsay shouting at some sheep did
i just watch this very quickly ever have
a look yummy yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
which one's going in the oven first
you
[Music]
there's bigger things to be worrying
about than this chef making i would
think he achieved what he wants to do
which is controversy and you know i mean
that's awesome
um what can i say i've loved you too
last night in a bun fight and mourinho
thank you very much dude richard size
thank you very much and thank you to you
for watching i really appreciate all the
involvement we will be back tomorrow
night they're not going to start
counting in my head because they don't
think i can tell the time but trust me i
can that's it from me whatever you're
doing keep it uncensored we're back
tomorrow night from may have a good
night see you tara thanks for watching
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the beast this simply does not wash look
who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i am zora solomon rebecca
vardy has insisted she never leaked any
stories about colleen rooney to the
press an allegation which led to the
explosive wagatha christie libel trial
which she lost last week as well as
blaming the judge she also lashed out at
rooney calling her cruel and unkind
life support treatment for archie
battersby is likely to be removed in the
next few days after the european court
of human rights refused an application
to delay the withdrawal of treatment
doctors believe the 12 year old is brain
dead and sadger javid has back liz trust
to be the next leader of the
conservatives he criticized his friend
rishi sunak saying his plans would lead
to a high tax low growth economy that's
all for now we'll have more after the
talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign